One of the things that happened during our
week off last week was that the impeached
president and people around him continued
to insist that impeachment is no concern at
all.
It's no big deal.
Everything's fine.
Trump impeached at whatever, it doesn't really
matter.
Trump's not worried, nobody's worried, and
yet Donald Trump spent the better part of
the last week, including nearly entire days,
rage tweeting about the fact that he has been
impeached on Christmas day, evening.
So Christmas day, the 25th at night, and then
the day after that Donald Trump could not
stop tweeting about Democrats and impeachment
and Nancy Pelosi, and even about home alone
too, if you can believe it.
On Christmas day, around 8:00 PM Eastern,
it began Trump quote, why should crazy Nancy
Pelosi just because she has a slight majority
in the house be allowed to impeach the president
of the United States got zero Republican votes.
There was no crime.
The call with Ukraine was perfect with no
pressure.
She said, it must be bi-partisan and overwhelming,
but this scam impeachment capitalizing scam
and impeachment, we don't know why was neither
also very unfair with no capital D due process,
proper representation or witnesses.
Now Pelosi is demanding everything the Republicans
weren't allowed to have in the house.
Dems wanna run majority Republican Senate
hypocrites.
So riddled with random capitalization riddled
with nonsequitors following it up with a series
of tweets from very, very early in the morning,
uh, all through later in the day, uh, alluding
once again to the upper Trump we've talked
about, you've got downer Trump or slowed down
Trump, which is the slurring Trump that often
shows up at rallies and speeches.
Later in the day.
We had video just in the last segment of that
version of Donald Trump from his speech to
turning point USA.
This Trump, which is the earlier in the day,
Trump or erratic hyped up seeming far more
manic, continuing to tweet, quote, the radical
left do nothing.
Democrats said they wanted to rush everything
through to the Senate because quote, president
Trump is a threat to national security.
They are vicious.
We'll say anything.
But now they don't want to go fast anymore.
They want to go very slowly.
Liars.
This is all so free of actual substance that
it doesn't really warrant specific refuting
beyond recognizing number one, this is an
unwell person.
Number two, this is a very scared person,
but again, how can Trump call them the do
nothing Democrats if they went and impeached
him, it seems they're doing things to the
extent that they can of course, without controlling
the Senate.
They're just not the things that Donald Trump
likes.
This is not the behavior of someone who isn't
worried about impeachment and of course more
than half the country supports him being an
impeached president, which is what he is.
This is the political equivalent to your neighbor.
Yelling, get off my lawn.
The little kids cutting across the corner
lot.
This is your wacky uncle, furious with a cloud
at Thanksgiving.
Nancy Pelosi has clearly triggered this guy
and we now are going to have to bear the brunt
of it for the next, how long, right?
I mean, possibly for the next year, possibly
for the next five years.
We could have five more years of this upcoming.
And by the way, now that we've had another
10 days of time to observe exactly as we predicted
before our vacation, Nancy Pelosi holding
the impeachment articles from the Senate for
now has worked exactly as we believed it would.
It has thrown Donald Trump into a tantruming
spiral, petulant child, uh, a mode that we
have seen to the nth degree.
Trump is impeached, and yet he now has to
wait before the trial gets going.
And it is driving him absolutely up a wall,
dozens and dozens of tweets about Nancy Pelosi.
He can't control himself and it is turning
out.
It's either by chance or by plan.
I don't know.
It is one of the most clever moves that Nancy
Pelosi has made.
She's done a lot of terrible, misguided things.
I think that actually the entire impeachment
being focused only around Ukraine was a mistake.
What about emoluments?
What about Yemen?
There's so many other things that are arguably
even stronger, but this holding of the articles
of impeachment for the time being has worked
really well.
We could expect Trump to continue tantruming
all throughout the new years holiday and well
into 2020 maybe this will even be the subject
or at least discussed during Donald Trump's
state of the union address early in 2020 although
at the same time his advisors may successfully
convince him not to talk about that.
We will see a but this is working really well
and so far actually a pretty good move by
Nancy Pelosi amidst many not so good moves.
So we will continue covering this and Trump's
reaction and Republican defenses including
on Instagram.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram while you were there
at David.
Dot Pacman.
Lots of videos and pictures from my vacation
last year,
some of which have people, uh, are quite titillated
I will say.
But I will say no more.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this